[Musique]
star indétrônable des années 80 jean luc
lahaye incarner cette période bénie avec
succès durant une décennie il a enflammé
le dancefloor notamment avec des tubes
comme femmes que j'aime ou encore
débarqué mois
pourtant rien ne prédestinait cet enfant
de la dass à devenir une star de la
chanson française après une adolescence
un peu chaotique clairsemée de quelques
délits jean-luc trouve finalement sa
voix dans la musique une période faste
durant laquelle il écoulé un million
deux cent mille exemplaires de son
single papa chanteur
si des années 90 sont plus difficiles
pour le chanteur il fait un come back
remarqué en 2004 notamment grâce à
l'émission retour gagnant qu'il remporte
jean luc lahaye surf avec talent sur la
nostalgie des années 80 en participant à
des tournées mais aussi aux films star
80 dans lequel il fait preuve d'une
grande autodérision star des années 80
tu dis aux premiers mots second degré
tout le monde a déjà dansé au moins une
fois sur les tubes mythiques de cet
artiste qui traverse décidément toutes
les décennies
merci loïc torino gilles de nous avoir
rejoints chef de l'actuelle ici paris et
comme je vous lise et jean luc lahaye
été placé en garde à vue avec sa fille
pour une affaire de viol sur mineure
regardez petit récapitulatif on aura
toutes les infos ensuite
c'est une nouvelle affaire d'agression
qui vient entacher la carrière de jean
luc lahaye nous sommes toujours préféré
être avec une compagne un peu plus jeune
chanteur à succès dans les années 80 il
a été confronté plusieurs fois des
affaires du même type ma préférence va
plutôt vers une fille de 20 ans que mon
âge aujourd'hui le parisien révèle que
l'homme de 68 ans aurait été interpellé
ce mercredi matin par les policiers de
l'office central pour la répression des
violences aux personnes et aurait été
placé en garde à vue avec une majeure
sexuelle je rappelle la noix est très
précise mais alors que s'est-il
réellement passé que risque jean luc
lahaye la réponse ce soir en plateau
c'est vrai que c'est tombé tout à
l'heure on s'est dit c'est pas possible
c'est il était pressé c'est incroyable
et toutes ces affaires en plus c'est
vrai qu'elle nous attriste un peu parce
qu'on vous dit voilà c'est incroyable
j'ai je sais que tu as vu la faire aussi
à louisville il a déjà eu quelques
lacets là c'est là on a passé un malade
en hausse qui
a passé un cap
c'est exactement là sa tension là on est
passé voilà lui alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé exactement merci loïc torino
gilles d'être là avec jean luc lahaye
qu'est-ce qui se passe donc on a on a
appris qu'il avait été interpellé ce
matin par les policiers de l'office
central pour la répression des violences
aux personnes alors si les faits sont
avérés ils sont quand même très grave
parce qu'elle fait un nom il est
soupçonné de viol et agression sexuelle
sur mineur de plus de 15 en détention
d'imagés pornographiques et corruption
de mineure alors corruption de mineurs
c'est le fait de profiter de la jeunesse
est un peu de la naïveté de
l'inexpérience on va dire de la victime
pour l'initier à 1 vise donc la de la
dépravation sexuelle et s'efforcer de le
rendre un peu exclamé esclave c'est
parce qu'elle était fan visiblement ils
disent qu elles étaient souvent très
exactement alors ses deux victimes
avaient 16 et 17 ans au moment des faits
présumés entre en 2013 et 2014
elle disait à l'époque déjà qu'elle
était sous l'emprise du chanteur et que
qui avait eu rapport sexuel et des
s'exclame c'est à dire il leur aurait
demandé de se déshabiller
en vidéo alors elle avait déjà porté
plainte à l'époque et ce qui est bizarre
c'est qu'elle avait fait marche machine
arrière elle s'était rétractée d'accord
donc début 2009 21 donc là tout
récemment l ombre eux déposé plainte
elles disent qu'elles ont eu une espèce
de une prise de conscience finalement
quelle qu'elle n'avait pas dénoncé le
diola époque mais qu'elles ont réalisés
finalement que ce qui leur était arrivé
n'était peut-être pas tout à fait normal
on parle toujours au conditionnel donc
depuis quelques mois il ya une enquête
préliminaire alors c'est à dire que la
la police à piolenc été autorisé par le
procureur et là j'en avais la place en
garde à vue dont qu'ils enquêtent depuis
quelques temps il ya quatre gardes à vue
juste l'histoire c'est pourquoi sa fille
est mise en garde à vue avec lui c'est
la question tout le monde se pose alors
on la soul à la kalach savions alors sa
fille à 36 ans à grands pas de bêtises
on la soupçonne de subordination de
témoin c'est à dire et de complicité de
subordination de témoin mais c'est à
dire d'avoir fait pression sur les
victimes présumées ce qui pourrait
expliquer en partie au conditionnel car
il faudrait pas que les jeunes filles il
ya en 2015 se soit rétractée d'accord ça
pour les pousser au silence ouais
d'accord c'est ça parce qu'on y va les
réveiller également deux femmes qui sont
mis en garde à vue dans cette affaire
sont les mamans des deux plaignantes
mais alors qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire parce qu'en fait on
soupçonnerait les mamans on quitte
également sous emprise parce
qu'également femme de jean luc lahaye
d'avoir incité leurs filles d'avoir tous
et leur fille dans les bras de jean luc
lahaye et de l'est de les avoir poussés
à faire à commettre ces actes c'est
affreux mais souvenez vous de l'histoire
de flavie flament c'est quand même sa
maman qu'il avait jetée dans la gueule
du loup donc malheureusement ce genre de
comportement il existe un mec c'est
propre aux enfants alors donc
aujourd'hui cette terre elle date de
2013 pourquoi le ressort que maintenant
elles ressortent comme un sens parce que
justement les deux jeunes filles ont
redit leur éclate donc la police a fait
une enquête alors on peut imaginer qu'il
ya dû avoir des écoutes téléphoniques la
surveillance quelque chose de classique
parce que si c'était début janvier ça
aura pris quand même eu huit neuf mois
avant que on décide de placer ses quatre
personnes en garde à vue il faut savoir
que
jean-luc avait été déjà condamné pour
cette affaire alors il avait été
condamné l'époque pour corruption de
mineur à un an de prison avec sursis
pour la plus jeune des victimes celles
et on lui reprocher oui pour une seule
des victimes et je me répète son manager
avait dit dans le parisien qu'il avait
eu très peur d'aller en prison et qui
s'étaient calmées oui dans les affaires
de viol pour miller bon présomption
d'innocence je rappelle à ses intérêts
toujours de viol d'un mineur de plus de
15 ans quelqu'un vous risquez 15 ans de
prison et tout ce qui est l'emprise
l'influencent que vous exercez sur des
mineurs qui peuvent vous vénérez sont
des circonstances aggravantes d'accord
donc là c'est vrai qu'il a vu cette
première condamnation pour corruption là
les enquêteurs qui travaillent depuis
plusieurs mois examiné d'abord c'est une
organisation familiale de jean luc
lahaye de sa fille effectivement pour
empêcher ces jeunes filles d'aller au
bout de leurs plaintes et de voir si à
l'époque et encore aujourd'hui il ya une
quelconque influence qu'il exercerait
sur ces deux jeunes filles jeunes femmes
et ça ça pourrait être des circonstances
très très aggravante d'accord alors
c'est pas lyrique je sais que vous avez
eu aussi des infos non mais voilà
toujours la faire voilà c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un combat on a
appris ça encore
aujourd'hui on rappelle aussi qu'il ya
vraiment une présomption d'innocence
aussi absolument là dessus les jeunes
filles et son calme maintenant
alors ils avaient 16 et 17 ans ou monde
et fait donc c'est en 2013
24 25 ans au procès s'était pardon de
s'adonner à des jeux sexuels par webcam
interposée jamais ces accords là ce qui
prétendument toujours pareil se réserve
tout cela n'a jamais été prouvé qu'ils
demanderaient aux jeunes filles de faire
des choses de à travers les webcams
voilà oui gilles précisons également
puisqu'on en parle souvent dans ces
affaires là qu'il n'ira il n'y aa il n'y
aura pas de prescription c'est très
important de le dire puisque depuis la
loi schiappa la prescription pour des
viols sur mineure a été porté à 30 ans à
compter de la majorité de la victime
présumée donc cette affaire elle ira au
bout il y aura pas de prescription sur
cette affaire quand une fois présomption
d'innocence mais il n'y aura pas un
tarissement de la source qu'est ce qui
risque aujourd'hui il risque plus que
quinze ans si jamais il y a
la hyène récidive était à une première
fois
jusqu'à 20 ans de prison et
ses antécédents judiciaires concernant
la justice pourrait demander son
placement en détention premier direct à
la gare d'agde en prison et et surtout
pour éviter tout contact ça pourrait
être ça c'est à dire que si jamais on ne
sait pas encore là mais si jamais elle
était placée en détention moi je serai
parce qu'encore une fois les enquêteurs
estiment qu'il pourrait tenter encore
d'entrer en contact avec les victimes
présumées pour les inciter à se taire et
il sa fille risque cole a fait 2 go pour
subordination de témoin elle reste
éventuellement quelques années de prison
mais on peut quand même ouais
non non non ce que je veux dire c'est
que d'après les infos qu'on a avec
bernard là elle est entendue mais c'est
plutôt pour tenter de la faire craquer
pour tenter de sa santé sa part le voilà
encore une fois il peut y avoir des
mises en examen de tout le monde mais
c'est plutôt donc comment dire
le maillon faible et vente
éventuellement de ce bloc soudé oui on
peut considérer que elle aussi à quelque
part était sous l'emprise de son père
c'est subordination de témoin pour elle
quoi qu'il arrive on n'ira pas en taule
ça c'est sûr aujourd'hui les proches de
jean luc faÿ réagissent comment vous les
avez pu les avoir pas du tout on n'a pas
plu du tout les avoir mais je suppose
qu'ils sont dépités d'accord une telle
affaire sorte parce que même si alors
c'est vrai qu'elle a déjà été condamné
mais il reste il faut le rappeler
présumé innocent mais on voit que sur sa
carrière veut ça déjà des répercussions
puisqu'il a été déprogrammée d'un
festival en septembre
la gym tout récemment parce que c'est
vrai que sur twitter beaucoup de gens
s'était insurgé qu'on évite un
pédocriminels alors le terme est fort et
donc on peut penser que ça va pas aider
pour la suite de sa carrière après il a
parfois joué avec le feu on se souviens
d'une phrase malheureuse au moment de sa
condamnation et la sortie du film star
je me rappelle plus exactement la phrase
mais il a il y avait un petit jeu de mot
sur le fait qu'il aimait les gels et
fille très jeune et qu'il avait dû il
avait dû aux falloir remonter la bande
annonce et ça fait toute une très grosse
polémique oui puis une autre fois il a
dit je les choisis sur échographie
gilles ce qui est très étonnant c'est
qu'on a travaillé avec eux avec valérie
et géraldine et on a retrouvé trace en
2015 de d'une lettre du conseil
départemental des hauts-de-seine est
également d'une l'aide du conseil
régional qui concernait son association
l'association fameuse association 120
lits et déjà à l'époque et déjà à
l'époque le conseil départemental disait
je nous voulons que son nom soit retiré
des antennes de toute communication y
compris des bulletins de salaire nous ne
cautionnons pas jean-luc lahaye donc y
compris au niveau des instances il y
avait autour de son nom déjà des doutes